[Music]
on this Wednesday night a delayed
evacuation fuels frustration the charter
plane stuck in Vietnam as stranded
Canadians waited out in Wuhan China they
how the US is coming to the rescue
plus the cruise ships now under lockdown
we can't even open the door and walk
down the Carter breaking news on
breaking ranks the member of President
Trump's own party voting to remove him
from the White House and astronomical
milestone one female astronauts rise
into the record books again
global national with Donna freezing
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us they are stressed
desperate and still stuck in China
tonight
Canadians hoping to leave the epicenter
of the new coronavirus outbreak are
delayed another day but there is a
silver lining late today the Foreign
Affairs Minister confirmed a u.s. option
we had an offer by the US State
Department who's going to have a plane
which will be departing shortly after
our own plane to put a number of
Canadians on board Ottawa is also
working to help hundreds of Canadians
stranded on a cruise ship off the coast
of Japan quarantined after confirmed
cases on board the World Health
Organization says the numbers have
surged globally in the past 24 hours we
saw the most reported cases in a single
day
the organization is requesting 675
million dollars in aid to help fight the
spread and today the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation answered the call
donating up to a hundred million dollars
to vaccine research and treatment
efforts the federal government is
encouraging all Canadians who do not
need to be in China to leave while they
still can so far 373 Canadians in Wuhan
have asked for help in our top story
tonight
Abigail Beeman reports on what it's
going to take to get them home
a city of 11 million people desolate for
days video sent to global news by Miriam
LaRouche one of 211 Canadians who was
supposed to be out by now
I got email an hour before leaving for
the airport this email from Global
Affairs Canada telling her the
evacuation flight was delayed narrow
window given by the Chinese for flights
into Han and the weather conditions were
such that the plane couldn't take off so
everything's delayed by a day Ottawa
says crosswinds were the problem on the
way to Vietnam the latest numbers show
373 Canadians want help getting out 211
are on the manifest Wednesday afternoon
the US State Department called Canada's
foreign affairs minister with a friendly
offer
we now have secured a few seats on a
flight Sargon eyes by the United States
authorities individuals who are eligible
for travel on this flights are being
contacted as we speak Francois Philippe
champagne will only say a few dozen
seats are up for grabs and Canada may
still send a second plane for the rest
meanwhile Global Affairs has updated its
travel advisory for China still warning
against any non-essential travel but
there's a new suggestion for Canadians
already there if you don't have to be to
come home now while commercial flights
are available when the Canadian flight
and the US flight with Canadians aboard
eventually land everyone will be taken
to an Ontario military base for 14 days
of quarantine we are going to be the
quarantine because and there's a new
recommendation from Canada's chief
Public Health Officer dr. Teresa Tam is
advising anyone who returned from whom a
province in the last two weeks to limit
contact with others what the u.s. is
calling self isolation although she
stresses the risk remains low Robin
Abigail vmon in awe
well hon is pretty much a ghost town
because of the quarantine and fears of
her how quickly the virus is spreading
there are now more than 28,000 confirmed
cases of the new corona virus worldwide
25 countries are affected including
Belgium for the first time and at least
five hundred and sixty-five people are
dead more than 5,500 people are stranded
on to quarantine cruise ships near Japan
and Hong Kong the world dream is docked
at Hong Kong's Kai Tak cruise terminal
with 1,800 people on board and the
diamond princess is anchored off the
coast of Yokohama near Tokyo with more
than 3700 people on board including 251
Canadians now ten more people who have
tested positive are coming off that ship
and being taken to hospital Redman
Shannon shows us how it all began nine
passengers and one crew member taken off
the diamond princess and in to
quarantine the ten none of whom are
Canadian tested positive for a new
coronavirus sanzu team even though
Japan's health minister says the other
three and a half thousand people will
stay on board for two weeks others on
board could yet test positive - we
remain confined to our cabins we can't
even open the door and walk down the
corridor
David Abel has been passing the time
chatting to the world's media the only
interaction that we're actually getting
is when a guy out onto the balcony and
talk to other passengers equally as
board and it's nice to talk to them in
the meantime there is little Ottawa can
do for the 251 Canadians on board we
will look at the cruise line in this
case to repatriate those Canadians when
the quarantine which has been decided by
local Health Authority is finished a
similar situation in Hong Kong where 30
passengers on this ship have a fever all
1,800 are being tested at the time being
I think we cannot conclude the likely
time of finishing the the quarantine
measures right now in a sector that
sometimes has to deal with virus
outbreaks one travel expert says
communication is key it's really
providing your car
murrs with the fax you know this is what
we're doing this is we have as a
precaution if you do have to take a
drastic measure informing your customer
about what you're doing people want to
be aware they want to be informed
something people on this ship may
appreciate it's been denied permission
to dock in the Philippines but has no
confirmed cases one Canadian passenger
tweeted not sure how or when but it will
be good to get home the operator told
global news it will be 10 days before
the ship can dock Redman Shannon Global
News London Hong Kong and Russia are
taking new mandatory measures aimed at
stopping the spread of the deadly virus
starting Saturday Hong Kong will
quarantine all visitors from mainland
China for 14 days it's unclear where the
quarantine will happen or how long this
measure will be in place in Russia 144
citizens arrived home today from Wuhan
they will be under quarantine for two
weeks at a camp in Siberia it's equipped
with fencing security cameras and
military guards so far none of the
evacuees is showing symptoms Russia says
all citizens who wanted out of China are
now back in their home country Russia
has already limited travel to and from
China by restricting flights and border
crossings one of the world's largest
carriers is slashing about 90% of its
flights to mainland China and now it's
asking employees to take unpaid leave
Cathay Pacific is appealing to its
27,000 workers including dozens based in
Vancouver to take three weeks off
between March 1st and the end of June
without pay the airline says coronavirus
has caused a significant drop in demand
and it needs to preserve cash to protect
the business cafe used similar special
leave in 2009 during the financial
crisis and in 2003 during the SARS
outbreak Canada's ambassador to China is
in Ottawa tonight speaking at the
special parliamentary committee created
to examine ottawa's tense relationship
with China Dominic Barton was directly
asked about the Canadians being detained
in Beijing are Ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson joins us now
Mercedes was there any indication
that the men will be released soon there
is no indication that that will happen
Robin there's no indication of what the
timeline might look like but ambassador
Barton did say that the plight of those
two men as well as Robert schellenberg a
Canadian who has been sentenced to death
in China are top of mind for him every
single day
here is part of what he told the MPs at
the committee at just how much of a
priority this is for him I want to say
also the utmost priority of my goal and
objectives is to work for the release of
Michael Kohlberg and Michael Michaels
favor and to see clemency for Robert
schellenberg that's right in the
headlights and I think about that every
day Robin he revealed the personal side
of being the ambassador and what the
contact has been like with mr. Kovarik
in mr. Spade or there's been very
limited contact with officials and we
don't hear much about their conditions
but we found out today that ambassador
Barton has actually met with them
personally watch this I am unbelievably
inspired by their resilience each of
these three people it's incredible as
humans and as individuals now he's had
that chance to meet with them he's
trying to work on the relationship with
China he says but it is difficult
he said ever since the arrest of Mohonk
o the CFO qua way the relationship has
changed radically the chill is real and
he described both sides as being very
angry in high-level meetings including
when he met with Chinese president G and
presented his papers here is how he
described the situation that he's
dealing with between Canada and China at
this time they're angry were very angry
because of our people that have been
taken China is very angry as well about
the Matt furious right were fierce we're
both furious
he says he believes the best way forward
is to continue to engage the Chinese but
not to be bullied and to have the
support of other countries he also
revealed that he met with officials from
Huawei and that he did raise the case of
the two Michels but he said it was not a
negotiation robbing Mercedes Stevenson
in Ottawa - breaking news in Washington
where the impeachment trial of President
Donald Trump has just come to an end the
US Senate voted to acquit Trump on two
articles of impeachment but Republican
senator Mitt Romney broke ranks and
voted with Democrats our Washington
bureau chief Jackson prosecco joins us
now with more Jackson how significant is
Romney's defection well Robin it's
historic it's the first time in history
that a senator has voted to impeach a
president of his own party what this
means is that despite Trump's claims
that impeachment was a partisan witch
hunt by Democrats there were in fact
bipartisan calls for his removal from
office Romney is of course the current
Republican senator for Utah and a former
Republican presidential candidate he was
emotional as he announced that decision
to vote against the president and says
he's well aware that he'll likely face
political reprisals from Trump and his
supporters the president is guilty of an
appalling abuse of public trust what he
did was not perfect no it was a flagrant
assault on her electoral rights our
national security and our fundamental
values corrupting an election to keep
oneself in office is perhaps the most
abusive and destructive violation of
one's oath of office that I can imagine
despite Romney voting against party
lines and the acquittal a foregone
conclusion this really has little impact
on the 20/20 campaign doesn't it Jackson
Robin I have to tell you the partisan
split in this country is so deep right
now that it's hard to believe that
impeachment is going to move the needle
either way in fact President Trump just
recorded his highest approval rating of
his presidency
49% according to a new Gallup poll and
that happened on the eve of this
historic impeachment but Trump also
can't escape the fact that he has
received bipartisan condemn
for his actions both toward Ukraine and
the Biden's the fact that Mitt Romney
delivered that stunning rebuke today
will certainly sting and it's worth
noting that several other Republicans
despite voting to acquit Trump have
expressed discomfort with his actions
but we really have to wait and see if
any of that resonates with voters Robin
Trump says he's going to address his
acquittal tomorrow from the White House
Jackson prosecco in Washington breaking
news from Hollywood tonight actor Kirk
Douglas has died we'll look back at his
life coming up we have breaking news
from the entertainment world veteran
actor Kirk Douglas one of the few stars
left from Hollywood's golden age has
died at the age of 103
his son actor Michael Douglas confirmed
the news tonight in a statement on
Facebook with more on the life and
career of Kirk Douglas here's Eric
Sorenson
[Music]
in his very first movie Hollywood
recognized Kirk Douglas would be a star
not only could he speak his edgy
impassioned portrayals saw him quickly
cast alongside Hollywood heavyweights
your hands are sweaty when you pull the
trigger finger or flip Bourne is sir
Danielle ovitch demske two Russian
immigrants Douglas could play at light
or musical
[Music]
but he was usually tough and
temperamental playing a troubled boxer
brought him his first Oscar nomination
good girl go to the iron I put you in
the hospital for a long long time now go
on with steel jaw raspy voice and
undeniable charisma his explosive
characters were riveting how do you know
how I feel about you how deep it goes
his most famous role was Spartacus a
slave who leads a revolt against the
corrupt Roman Empire the epic cemented
Douglas's place among hollywood's most
respected actors but making Spartacus
was also a turning point in 1950s
America Douglass helped in the era of
blacklisting Hollywood talent for
alleged communist sympathies real-life
drama brought to film years later Bolden
when Kirk Douglas insisted blacklisted
writer Dalton Trumbo be given an
onscreen credit for Spartacus there's a
good story in there somewhere the
douglases character was instantly
recognizable 60 years later was a
reminder of how familiar he was in their
heyday Impressionists all did Kirk
Douglas because the whole world knew him
drill a hole and his acting style of
barely contained rage Douglass loved it
to say he had a long career is an
understatement
my wife even approaching 100 he was
still active with many charities his
legacy includes his son Michael Douglas
himself a famous actor I'll see it
simply with all my heart I'm so proud to
be yourself one of the last stars from
Hollywood's golden era moviegoers knew
what they were getting in a Kirk Douglas
film and they loved what they got from
Kirk Douglas
Eric Sorenson global news
still ahead the crash lining in Turkey
and house cause of passengers were
forced to escape plus air being these
new house rules for younger clients
after a deadly shooting
Airbnb is introducing new restrictions
on young renters in Canada in the wake
of a deadly shooting at a downtown
Toronto condo
the pilot policy will prohibit people
under the age of 25
from renting homes within their own
community unless there's a host on the
premises the move is meant to prevent
unauthorised house parties and does not
apply when people are renting outside
their community in this particular case
as it relates to Canada our research
shows that those incidents involving
unauthorized parties do significantly
over-index
with people under the age of 25 doing on
hosted stays within the communities that
they live in three people died last
Friday in a shooting at a downtown
Toronto condo that had been rented out
on Airbnb a fourth man was hospitalized
with serious gunshot wounds all of the
victims were between the ages of 19 and
22 Canada has demanded Iran hand over
the black boxes from the wreckage of the
Ukrainian passenger plane that Iran's
military shot down last month all 176
people on board died including 57
Canadians Canada's foreign affairs
minister says he has requested
international help to pressure Iran
saying the world is watching always said
you know we judge Iran by their actions
not their word and day by day clearly
now the annex 13 of the International
Civil Aviation Convention calls for the
black box to be read and analyzed
without delay Iran doesn't even have the
right equipment to download that
critical data but won't give up the
flight recorders now a new poll done
exclusively for global news shows many
Canadians want the government to take a
hard-line approach to change that our
chief political correspondent David akin
is looking at the numbers and whether
Canada should re-establish diplomatic
ties with Tehran David Robin while the
investigation into the downing of that
Ukrainian airliner appears to be mired
in delay a new poll for global news done
by Ipsos shows that Canadians are in
broad agreement about two key issues
sanctions and reparations
more than three-quarters of Canadians
believe the Government of Canada should
increase sanctions against the
government of Iran that support is
strong right across the board regardless
of political affiliation gender or
region there is even stronger consensus
when it comes to pressing Iran to pay
damages to the families of the 57
Canadians killed when Iranian missiles
shot down that plane nearly 90 percent
of Canadians agree Iran should pay
reparations support that is again
consistent across party lines gender or
region but there is some difference of
opinion when it comes to support for
re-establishing diplomatic relations
with Iran relations which the
conservative harper government cut off
in 2012 in response to Iran's support
for the Assad regime in Syria and for
threats against Israel the Trudeau
Liberals promised to restore diplomatic
relations during the 2015 election
campaign but have not yet done so now
among those who voted liberal in
October's federal election 66% agree
Canada should re-establish diplomatic
relations 69% of New Democrats and 63%
of Bloc Quebecois voters also agree with
that idea but just 47 percent of
conservative voters believe it is time
to re-establish formal ties with Iran
for now though the government of
candidates priorities are to move
forward with the investigation as to the
future of Canada Iran relations Canadian
officials say that's a discussion for
another day Robin David akin in Ottawa
some terrifying moments at an airport in
Istanbul a passenger plane broke into
several pieces and burst into flames
after it skidded off the runway and
crashed into a field emergency personnel
swarmed the Boeing 737 to rescue
passengers many of whom had to escape
through cracks in the smashed plane it
belonged to low-cost carrier Pegasus
Airlines the plane was arriving from a
Western Province in Turkey and was
carrying a hundred and seventy-one
passengers and six crew members there
was heavy rain and strong winds at the
time of the crash
in eastern Turkey emergency crews
desperately tried to dig survivors out
of deep snow an avalanche slammed into a
mountain road wiping out a huge team of
rescue workers sent to find people
missing in an earlier snow slide at
least 38 people were killed in the two
avalanches dozens more were injured a
fossilized skeleton belonging to an
ancient iguana like creature that roamed
the ocean more than 200 million years
ago
has been discovered preserved in rock in
southeastern Alaska the species of
marine reptile is called the lattice or
meaning ocean lizard and it's a distant
cousin of the dinosaurs that lived
during the Triassic period they have
been found in the past but this one is
different it has a needle-like snout and
as the only intact the lattice or fossil
ever found in North America zero gravity
mega record affects the astronaut who
broke the highest glass ceiling three
astronauts are heading home tonight
including Christina cook she spent three
hundred and twenty eight days on the
International Space Station breaking the
record for the longest stint in space by
a woman and as Eric Sorenson explains
it's not the only record she was a part
of as women catch up to the achievements
of men the bell signals today's command
hand over to a new crew aboard the
International Space Station it caps a
phenomenal flight for American Christina
cook cooks 11 months in space was only
12 days short of the all-time record for
a single mission Christina relocates the
apsr cook and fellow astronaut Jessica
Muir also blazed a trail when they
worked outside the spacecraft together
the first ever all-female spacewalk she
and I both really appreciated and loved
that it could serve as inspiration for
future space explorers
the very first woman in space was
valentina Tereshkova of the Soviet Union
in 1963 she followed eleven men into
space everyone wants to be an abaya
and was a hero in the soviet union even
if the description sounds out-of-date he
it seemed to be Tereshkova was the first
and for a long time the only woman in
space the very first space traveler was
Soviet cosmonaut Yuri Gagarin in April
1961 over the next 20 years to April
1981 there were 103 astronauts mostly
Soviet and American men and there was
Tereshkova one woman representing less
than 1% of all astronauts today after
almost 60 years of spaceflight
there have been 564 astronauts in total
women now account for 65 of them or just
over 11% it's progress
Canada did its part to breakthrough the
atmospheric glass ceiling our first
astronaut was Marc Garneau but the
second was Roberta Bondar
she and later Julie Payette performed
every bit as well as the men who had
gone before and while women haven't
caught up in sheer numbers they have
closed the gap as more embrace science
and technology as that pipeline of women
in STEM and other underrepresented folks
in the STEM fields grows we hope to then
capitalize on that and bring that
innovation and talent into the astronaut
corps and someday perhaps the
breakthroughs will come not just for
being the first woman but simply being
the first period
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto well
said that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is Richmond BC we would love to
see you're part of this country so email
us your pictures thank you for watching
and have a great night
[Music]